Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now we're gonna
get to the news.
After a clip
was released yesterday
of former President Trump
storming out of an interview
with journalist Piers Morgan,
a spokesman for Trump
called the preview a
"pathetic attempt
to revive the career
of a failed television host."
Buddy, you're gonna
have to be more specific.
[ Laughter ]
That's right --
Piers Morgan released a clip
from an interview
with former President Trump
that he claims will be
"the most explosive interview
of the year."
Well, it's certainly
gonna be the sweatiest!
I mean, look --
He looks like Jigsaw
just told him he has an hour
to name all the state capitals.
[ Laughter ]
After the Capitol attack,
Senate Majority Leader --
Sorry -- Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
reportedly told --
he was the majority at the time.
[ Laughter ]
No, he wasn't. Was he?
After January 6th, was he?
-Yeah. Before, right?
-Yeah, but on January -- Oh, no,
he wasn't. You know what?
I think the important thing
right now
is that this is good television.
[ Laughter ]
Nobody's gonna argue that.
After the Capitol attack,
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
reportedly told his advisers
that he thought
former President Trump was
responsible for the insurrection
and added, "
The Democrats are going to
take care of
the son of a bitch for us."
Oh, come on, Mitch. You've been
around politics for a long time.
When have the Democrats
ever taken care of anything?
[ Laughter and groans ]
Rudy Giuliani appeared on --
Oh, I'm sorry
you had to find out here.
[ Laughter ]
Rudy Giuliani appeared on
"The Masked Singer" last night
in a jack-in-the-box costume
and sang the song
"Bad to the Bone."
I mean,
that is just unbelievable.
Somebody famous
was on "The Masked Singer"!
[ Laughter ]
The new CNN Plus
streaming service
is reportedly shutting down
on April 30th
after launching
less than a month ago.
Well, I'm not surprised.
You already have
a 24-hour news channel,
and you couldn't even
fill that with news.
Don't get me wrong.
I'd watch Tucci go anywhere.
The Trump International Hotel
in Washington, D.C.,
is set to be sold
in the coming days
to a Florida-based
investor group
led by this intriguing
mystery man.
[ Laughter ]
Disney World on Tuesday lifted
its remaining mask requirements,
and it is really
freaking out the kids.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Tyranny's over!
[ Laughter ]
The organizers
of the Tony Awards
have issued a warning
to attendees
that this year's ceremony has
a "strict no-violence policy,"
which is obviously a response
to that time that guy shot
Alexander Hamilton.
[ Laughter ]
People love "Hamilton" so much,
they were, like, "Yeah!"
A man in Canada
recently discovered
through a DNA test
that his biological father
was his former co-worker,
though he probably should have
figured it out sooner.
[ Laughter ]
Just, I like when
I have to wait a second
'cause it's a reading joke.
[ Laughter ]
Today was National Tea Day.
Oh, do you guys want some tea?
In that case...
[Whispering]
Wally's getting fired later.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm kidding.
I went to the network brass
and I said,
"Either he goes or I go!"
And they're like,
"Have a great day."
And finally,
according to the latest numbers,
by this summer,
Netflix is projected to lose
around 2 million subscribers.
To combat this, they're tweaking
the app a little.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!